si va a tener un parto vaginal el doctor
puede realizar una episiotomía para
agrandar la abertura vaginal
durante el embarazo el bebé crece dentro
del útero o matriz y se alimenta por la
placenta
cuando el bebé está listo para nacer
comienza el trabajo de parto durante el
trabajo de parto el útero se comprime o
se contrae para empujar al bebé a través
del cuello uterino abierto y hacia la
vagina la que se expande para permitir
el paso del bebé y su nacimiento se
puede realizar una episiotomía a fin de
evitar el desgarre espontáneo durante el
parto si el bebé es grande o está de
nalgas si el trabajo de parto se está
produciendo demasiado rápido o si se
necesitan instrumentos como fórceps o
ventosa obstétrica para sacar al bebé
del canal de parto se puede realizar una
episiotomía para ayudar a acelerar el
parto si el trabajo de parto va
demasiado lento o si usted o el bebé
están sufriendo
si no ha recibido anestesia antes del
parto el doctor le inyectará medicamento
para adormecer la abertura vaginal y el
perineo que es el área que separa la
vagina del ano el médico utilizará una
tijera quirúrgica para realizar una
incisión de entre una y tres pulgadas 25
y 75 centímetros en la línea media o
medio lateral del perineo una incisión
en la línea media se extiende de forma
recta desde la vagina hacia el ano una
incisión medio lateral se realiza en
ángulo desde la vagina en la dirección
del ano
la ventaja de la incisión medio lateral
es que existe menor probabilidad de que
se produzca un desgarre del ano sin
embargo la desventaja es que puede ser
más dolorosa y puede tardar más en
cicatrizar una vez que el médico saca al
bebé y a la placenta cerrará la incisión
de la episiotomía con puntos
y estos puntos serán absorbidos por el
propio cuerpo y no es necesario
quitarlos
por lo general una episiotomía cicatriza
sin complicaciones aunque puede llevar
varias semanas dentro de las primeras 24
horas la enfermera probablemente la
ayudará a aplicarse bolsas de hielo en
los puntos